hoy vamos a echar un vistazo a este
reproductor de dvd vamos a ver qué tiene
adentro y qué es lo que lo hace
funcionar hay varios componentes clave
por ejemplo vamos a ver la fuente de
alimentación también la placa de control
la charada del dvd o del cdm así como el
láser y la cubierta externa pero vamos a
comenzar este reproductor de dvd es en
realidad de bajo costo puedes comprarlo
por menos de 30 dólares y bueno la
manera en la que son capaces de reducir
el costo es en parte porque los chips
que tiene dentro que lo hacen funcionar
han bajado de precio y bueno por otra
parte también ha bajado de precio porque
son capaces de simplificar tremendamente
la cantidad de componentes en la placa
ok vamos a observar el interior esta
pista de metal es una lámina plana
sometida a una prensa y bueno tenemos
por aquí en estas pestañas
bloquean la cubierta debajo con la parte
delantera además por aquí tenemos estas
hendiduras estampadas que sirven para
alinear los tornillos los orificios son
perforados y después esta lámina de
metal es doblada ahora vamos a observar
qué hay dentro del reproductor de dvd
ten cuidado en esta ocasión tengo
conectado nuestro reproductor pero no es
seguro tener conectado algún dispositivo
electrónico cuando éste está abierto así
que no intentes esto en casa a menos de
que tengan un profesional entre ustedes
pero bueno quería mostrarles lo que
sucede cuando el dvd o bueno el cedem se
introducen en el reproductor y ver cómo
funciona lo que va a suceder en un
momento es lo siguiente esta bandeja va
a entrar y van a ver cómo esta placa de
atrás bajará para darle lugar a la
bandeja y después verán que se levantará
y el montaje del láser empezará a
deslizarse a través del dvd vamos a
poder ver que está encendido con él
el indicador ahora bien voy a cerrar la
charola para meterlo lo primero que voy
a hacer es presionar el botón de
reproducir y el dvd es atraído al
reproductor y pueden ver que el dvd se
levanta y lo que está sucediendo es que
la energía está siendo alimentada de
este puerto hasta la placa de control la
placa de control le dice a los motores
que hacer y además recopila la
información del láser para que después
la mande a estos puertos de aquí que
salen hacia tu televisión y son
mostradas como una señal
vamos a tratar de quitar el panel
frontal de esta unidad que es este de
kim el panel frontal el cual es una
pieza de plástico moldeado por inyección
y bueno si observas aloja la ranura por
donde salen la bandeja del disco y
además aloja una ventana donde el
infrarrojo que sale del control remoto
pueda penetrar para decir que se debe
hacer y tiene otro pequeño punto para el
led que indica cuando el aparato está
encendido o cuando está apagado en la
parte superior hay diferentes botones
estos botones son piezas que se hicieron
por separado y fueron moldeadas hay un
botón de expulsar y otro de reproducir
otro de pausar parar y encender un
diseño bastante simple y esta pieza es
probablemente de plástico abs aunque no
lleve la marca y por ningún lado dice a
bs pero observamos que tiene estas
lengüetas que entran a presión con el
resto del marco lo que
que sea más fácil unirlas y que el costo
sea bastante bajo